protesters attack a china mobile shop in
the past few days dozens of businesses
in Hong Kong have been vandalized during
clashes protesters often target
companies from the mainland such as the
state-owned telecom providers the big
Chinese banks and other industries tied
to the Beijing government but there are
less obvious choices like this famous US
coffee brand
Starbucks has been one of the top
targets this one has been vandalized
twice first they trashed the entrance
then then the next day the company set
up these wooden panels to protect it and
then the next day the protesters took
down these panels and continued trashing
this shop so it feels saddening and
frustrating at the same time this
consequence is due to the government's
which didn't listen to the citizens in
online groups protesters post messages
explaining their choice of targets Hong
Kong Starbucks branches are run by the
local caterer max Eames the company drew
the wrath of the protesters when the
founders daughter held a speech at the
UN Human Rights Council denouncing the
protests lexemes has distanced itself
from her statement saying she holds no
official position in the business but to
no avail
the logic of conflict has reached Hong
Kong's businesses between the ire of the
protesters and repercussions on the
Chinese market many of them are facing a
tough choice for this Starbucks branch
the only thing to do now is to renovate
and hope that they won't be targeted a
third time